[Music]
foreign
we will showcase the biggest
Transformers from the movie Rise of the
bees they are going to be our own
estimates until the official stats are
released the movie was great if you only
take into account the part where the
Transformers are on screen I just chose
to ignore the political agendas and only
look at the robots and their storyline
give the movie a chance Bros let's get
to it the smallest freezer this little
henchman of scourge they are the
smallest Transformers seen in the movie
they are the size of a frenzy from the
Beavers these smallest terracons are
roughly 1.5 to 1.8 meters or 5 to 6 feet
tall around the size of a human being
and number 19 we have Mirage plus Nova
Diaz yeah so technically not really a
Transformer but the human protagonist
Noah with the exoskeleton of Mirage
would have added a bit to his height
putting him around 2 meters or 6.5 feet
tall
number 18 Sans pure these are the
smaller type of the two scorpion-based
Terracon Sans spear in its alternate
mode is around 2 to 2.4 meters of 6.5 to
8 feet in height they were seen in the
last scenes of the final battle
number 17 scorpion up scorpino was seen
in the beginning at and the end of the
movie this was a large type of
scorpion-based Terracon in its alternate
mode it would have been 2.1 to 2.7
meters or 7 to 9 feet in height
number 16 RC this Autobot is the
smallest of the bunch she is a field
commander and was a fast and nimble
fighter which transformed into a Ducati
Superbike in the rise of the Beast as
her robot mode she stood around 2.4 to
2.7 meters tall or eight to nine feet
number 15 Mirage an infiltrator at a
scout Autobot replacing the role of
Bumblebee as the main liaison with the
human characters Mirage had a unique set
of abilities mainly creating Holograms
of himself he was small though being a
bit taller than a one-story building
therefore around 3.7 to 4.1 meters or 12
to 14 feet
14 nights birth the first of the
deadliest subordinates of scourge she
has a deadly combat robot a Terracon
powered by the dark Energon of Unicron
she can fly around and service both air
support as well as his couch ninth bird
was the size of Mirage around 3.7 to 4.3
meters or 12 to 14 feet tall
number 13 bumblebee an autobot's card
who transforms into a modified yellow
black 1970s Chevrolet Camaro later
equipped with all terrain extensions his
childlike demeanor and free spirit made
him a fan favorite and gained him an
invaluable plot armor let's say be here
is smaller than the Beavers version
around 4.3 to 4.9 meters around 14 to 16
feet tall
number 12 Terry Collins In the End
scenes of the movie the army of
terracons included scorpion variants
friezas and a third larger type which is
yet unnamed these larger terracons are
around the size of Bumblebee in height
which are 14 to 16 feet or 4.3 to 4.9
meters tall
number 11 wheel Jack in the Beavers
movies wheel Jack is portrayed as a
robot Einstein but in Rise of the Beast
he is a bigger and a better Autobot he
is also one of its finest scientists
Wheeljack had a vehicle form of a hippie
van in robot mode he was around 15 to 16
feet of 4.5 to 4.9 meters tall
and number 10 we have cheetor he has a
killing machine in both the bees and
robot versions striking hard and fast
with great reflexes cheetah and
Bumblebee are both Scouts and protectors
being someone alike in job profiles he
was very tall in robot mode around 20 to
24 feet or 6.1 to 7.3 meters
and number nine we have Optimus primal
Optimus primal is the lead of the
maximals his beast mode is a giant
silverback gorilla he is extraordinary
for not only being able to distinguish
himself despite being designed to follow
the pathway of Optimus Prime he was 6.7
to 7.3 meters or 22 to 24 feet in height
number eight ape link this was the
former leader of the maximals in their
home world and the one that bestowed
upon Primal to lead the survivors he was
also akin to a gorilla but a bit bigger
even in beast mode being 24 to 26 feet
or 7.3 to 7.9 meters in height
number seven Optimus Prime he is the
leader of the Autobots and one of the
most powerful Transformers in all
timelines and continuities in this
timeline he leads the remnants of the
Autobots that escaped Cybertron after
the Great War and got stuck on Earth
Prime was 7.3 to 7.9 meters or 24 to 26
feet in height
number six battle trap in vehicle mode
battle trap transforms into a yellow
orange GMC tow truck in truth he is a
Decepticon not a Terracon but in Rise of
the Beast is classified as a ladder
being created by Unicron he was larger
than Primal but around the same size as
Prime therefore around 26 feet or 7.9
meters tall
number five Scourge the leader of the
Terracon Army of Unicron Scourge was the
herald of The Great Devourer he was
bestowed great power which came from
dark Energon definitely a match or an
equal to Prime himself he was also
taller standing 8.5 meters or 28 feet in
height
number four rhinox he represents the
Maximus brute strength to disguise as a
massive rhinoceros he still played his
skin Shields him from most damage
including double Baron laser Weaponry
rhinos is truly a base and he stands
eight to nine meters or 26.5 to 30 feet
in height
number three air razor arrays of the
maximal wasn't seen in her robot mode in
the movie but in her alternative form
which took the appearance of a gigantic
Eagle she was even larger than Primal
she would be in the same size racist
rhinos therefore around 8 to 9 meters or
26.5 to 30 feet in height
number two Stratosphere he is a gigantic
Autobot who serves as a transport for
smaller Bots and supplies always
preferring the sky to the ground and
shying away from fighting he takes the
form of a large Transport Aircraft when
in robot mode he Towers over all the
rest twice that of Optimus Prime so
around 15 meters or 50 feet in height
and number one of course Unicron
obviously the largest and the biggest
Transformer aside from Primus itself in
any timeline and continuity here in the
movie he was bigger than a planet which
means he was bigger than planet Earth
hence putting him in the range of 10 000
miles or 16 000 kilometers in diameter
so that is the list of the smallest of
the biggest Transformers and Rise of the
beasts anyway I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos here on
this channel take care fam